c'est bien de toi de venir à une fête en
ayant l'air d'un [ __ ] laveur je ne suis
pas venu pour la fête allez faut que je
sache et leader pense que mes poèmes dis
le moi j'ai adoré que poèmes
j'aime toujours que poèmes mais je ne
peux plus mettre ta seule l'actrice
emily tu dois partager tes écrits avec
le monde
il ya quelqu'un qu'il faut que je te
présente
c'est mme bowles cet homme pour être ici
dans la célébrité
cela m'intéresse toujours entre nouvelle
voie
et si je ne veux pas être célèbre
comment voulez vous qu'on se souvienne
de vous
je suis enchanté de vous avoir fait vous
rencontrer tous les deux j'ai
l'impression d'avoir vu au destin c'est
dingue est une influence us
je veux surtout pas disparaître de cette
terre sans que quelqu'un sache qui je
suis avez vous vous aussi quelques
intentions les sorcières de salem nous
ont ouvert la voie
[Musique]
moi quand j'étais jeune je perds le
contrôle
vous allez très vite être mondialement
connu
son aura est négative en ce moment
j'avais toujours cette confiance mais je
ne veux plus depuis que j'ai rencontré
quelle drôle de journée se donne aussi
dingue que tous les trucs qui se passe
là où elle en fait vraiment trop
si tu pouvais cynique ce que tu es
l'afrique qui refuseraient
dit d'une opportunité unique dans une
vie c'est toi qui m'a forcé la main et
je ne me reconnais plus la célébrité
c'est comme
à mort la fillette au
une partie de moi est persuadé que la
gloire n'est pas pour moi
qu'en fait je crois qu'il pourrait être
très grand chose
[Musique]
quoi vous avez le cerveau en faire ça
m'étonne pas